Now, it turns out that the answer to both questions is k. Let's see why that is.
Now remember a clique is a sub-graph in which all of the vertices in the sub-graph
are connected to all the other vertices in the sub-graph--like for example this sub-graph,
now might be part of a larger graph--we don't really need to know that,
but this is a clique right in here.
So if we color just one of these vertices like this, well then we can't color
any of the other vertices with that color.
So we need as many colors as are in the largest clique and that would be k.
Now, for the second question, let's say we know that the graph can be colored with at most k colors
and that's all we need--we don't need more than k colors.
Well, then we know because the reason we just use--the largest clique can only have k vertices in it.
So as otherwise we wouldn't be able to use k colors in order to color the graph.